there are new calls for governors to
hold off on their planned lifting of
coronavias restrictions as
arizona joins texas mississippi and
connecticut
and announcing plans to cut or relax
coveted safety guidelines
members of president biden's coronavirus
task force say new variants of the virus
combined with reduced regulations
could lead to yet another spike in cases
it comes as the u.s sets a daily record
in new vaccinations now nearly 29
million americans are fully vaccinated
and with the new daily case count
averaging about 60 thousand this week
that's down 78 percent from the record
high set the first week of january
michael george is here with more this
morning good morning michael good
morning michelle new case numbers had
been dropping for weeks but
now they've plateaued and that's why dr
anthony fauci and other leading
scientists
are sounding the alarm they say efforts
to fully reopen
may be too much too soon
spring training in arizona opened up to
baseball fans
connecticut businesses are lifting
indoor capacity limits
movie theaters in new york are again
letting people in
small steps but a big concern that the
country
is making mistakes ones ohio's
republican governor
isn't willing to make yet victory is in
sight
it's just not here yet until we get to
that that point we've got to continue
to wear the mask and we've got to
continue to be careful the boldest move
by far came from texas where the
republican governor ended required mask
wearing this week
followed by mississippi in response a
barrage of continuous criticism
this action will take a number of states
back to dark days texas
mississippi alabama will be
some of the states will be going back to
the days of surge
and infection and death masks actually
got a boost from a new cdc study of
counties that allowed indoor dining
finding that those with mask mandates
had far lower rates of illness and death
the researchers found that increases in
both
daily death rates and coveted cases and
deaths slowed significantly within 20
days
of putting mass mandates into place but
while the country is
still stalled on the mask debate a year
into the pandemic
vaccine distribution moved steadily
ahead this week
state by state vaccination efforts have
added up to more than
80 million doses delivered more than 16
percent of the country has received at
least one dose
dr anthony fauci on instagram yesterday
provided a timeline to complete the
process
the logistic constraint of getting the
vaccine into people's arms
will probably take an additional few
months
so we project that anyone who wants to
get vaccinated
will have gotten vaccinated by the time
we get to the end of the summer
and the beginning of the fall and a lot
of americans are asking once you've been
vaccinated what should and
shouldn't you do well so far the cdc
hasn't given guidelines for vaccinated
people but
they're expected to issue them soon for
now the recommendation is to continue to
practice social distancing
and wearing masks jeff michael thank you